Heute im Rasenfunk?
Nein!
Der Blick auf andere Menschen.
Hallo und herzlich Willkommen in der Rasenfunk-Liga. Wie schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social und bei Blue Sky. Aber um niemanden könnte es weniger gehen als um mich. Star sind in der Ligatur die Gäste. Und da ist unter anderem hier Fabian Pakulat. Hallo Fabian, schön, dass du da bist. Wir können dich unter anderem auf viva.la.liga.de lesen. Wird natürlich wie immer verlinkt. Die Informationsquelle zum spanischen Fußball. Und ich weiß gerade noch nicht genau, wie viel man von deinem Video sehen wird. Aber du sitzt heute in einem ganz besonders schönen Setting, Fabian.
Ja, freut mich. Ich musste heute umziehen ins Kinderzimmer, ins Zimmer meines Sohnes. Aber es passt eigentlich wunderbar zur Sendung, wie ich finde.
Aber absolut, das finde ich auch. Spätestens jetzt allen alle zu YouTube. Und vielleicht sehen die es gar nicht, weil ich dich vielleicht abschneide. Ich weiß es noch nicht. Wer man auf jeden Fall sehen wird, denn da kann man nicht schneiden, ist Christian Bernhard, denn er sitzt neben mir. Hallo Christian, schön, dass du da bist.
Hallo Max, hallo in die Runde. Freut mich sehr.
Und wen wir nicht sehen, aber wir freuen uns umso mehr, dass er mit dabei ist, Uli Hebel. Hallo Uli. Ja, wir haben einen ereignisreichen Donnerstag jetzt schon hinter uns. Das kann man so sagen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Diese Ligatur, sie findet unter besonderen Umständen statt. Deswegen, ja, umso mehr Danke an die Gäste. Dass sie mit dabei sind. Wir wollen gleich mal reinstarten. Und ich würde sagen, Fabian, du warst der Erste, der hier im Call war. Deswegen darfst du jetzt als erstes eins deiner Themen mitbringen. Und du bist ja immer der Mann. Das mag ich sehr für die etwas überraschenden Vereinsnennungen. Über wen wirst du denn zuerst sprechen?
Na, wenn du jetzt schon so anfängst, dann muss ich ja quasi mit meinem zweiten Team anfangen. Und dann möchte ich gerne über den Aufsteiger UD Las Palmas sprechen. Das ist dieses Jahr der beste Aufsteiger in der spanischen Liga. Und er hat laut Transfermarkt sogar nur ein insgesamtes Kaderbudget von unter 60 Millionen Euro. Sprich, er gehört zu den ärmsten Teams der Liga. Er zeichnet sich aber seit Jahren für sehr gute Nachwuchsarbeit aus. Viele Eigengewächse werden dort gezüchtet, wenn ich das so sagen darf. Las Palmas steht eigentlich immer für einen sehr attraktiven, offensiven Spielstil. Dieses Jahr ist es zudem noch sehr erfolgreich. Sie sind der Aufsteiger, stehen im Moment auf Tabellenplatz 8, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Sie machen einen guten Job und haben dann noch ein paar Spieler in ihren Reihen, die im Moment ganz eigene Erfolgsgeschichten schreiben.
Die Erfolgsgeschichten aus Spielerkreisen will ich gleich mal hören. Aber weil du sagst, erfolgreicher Fußball, Aufsteiger, ist das jetzt –ihr wisst ja, ich kann nicht ohne die Bundesliga –ist das jetzt der VfB Stuttgart in La Liga? Was kennzeichnet denn den Offensivfußball von Las Palmas? Warum funktioniert das?
Heidenheim und Darmstadt ist es auf jeden Fall nicht. Für Stuttgart ist es dann doch zu wenig. Aber nein, sie sind wirklich unwahrscheinlich Ball. Auf Ballbesitz ist das Ganze ausgelegt. Der Ball zirkuliert sehr schnell und sehr viel in den eigenen Reihen. Und sie sind technisch sehr versiert. Also es ist wirklich auch so, dass da Spieler dabei sind, die auch im 1 gegen 1 sehr stark sind normalerweise. Und im heutigen Fußball oder allgemeinen im Fußball ist es ja einfach so, wenn du die Chance hast, einen Spieler zu haben, der auch mal einstehen lassen kann, dann geben sich dann eben die Räume. Und da ist Las Palmas im Moment richtig stark. Man kann dann eben sehr gute Nadelstiche setzen gegen die anderen Teams der Liga.
Dann nenne uns doch mal ein paar dieser Spieler. Wer ist denn da so herausragend?
Also im Moment der Herausragendste ist eigentlich Kirian Rodriguez. Zu dem möchte ich später noch ein bisschen kommen, wenn wir über die MVP sprechen, da kann ich ein bisschen mehr auf seine Geschichte eingehen, die auch sehr interessant ist. Aber nur so viel, er war sehr lange verletzt, sehr lange nicht mehr dabei und war eigentlich einer der größten Talente, vielleicht Spaniens, inzwischen glaube ich ist er 27. Und er kommt jetzt wieder gerade rein und hat, wie gesagt, eine lange Krankheit hinter sich und schießt im Moment die wichtigen Tore, ist im Mittelfeld gesetzt und hat neben ihm einen Mann stehen, den ich auch sehr interessant finde, das ist der 20-jährige Alberto Moleiro, unwahrscheinlich starker Tripler, Techniker. Ich kenne diese Spieler schon aus der Vorsaison, als Las Palmas und auch der FC Malaga noch in der zweiten Liga waren. Jetzt sind sie ja so ein bisschen auseinandergedrift, die beiden. Deswegen hat es mich überrascht, dass ich tatsächlich viele Spieler wiedererkenne, die auch im letzten Jahr in der zweiten Liga schon erfolgreich waren. Sie haben wirklich nicht viel eingekauft und machen das wirklich ganz gut. Sie haben dann noch einen Spieler oder zwei Ex-Basa-Schützlinge in ihren Reihen, mit Sandro Rodriguez und mit El Hadadi. Die waren beide mal oder sind in der Basa-Akademie aufgewachsen und haben dann schon ein bisschen einen Roundtrip gemacht durch die Primärdivision. Sandro war ja auch mal in der Premier League, war übrigens auch mal beim FC Malaga, als wir noch Erstliga-Mannschaft waren. Und auch die machen ihren Job richtig gut. Und Sandro kommt auch selbst von den Kanaren. Also da passt vieles im Moment zusammen. Sie haben auch einen sehr guten Trainer, wie ich finde. Und der ist auch schon seit, ich glaube jetzt seit Anfang 2022 da. Also war auch schon in der Zweitliga mit den Jungs dabei. Und ja, das ist ein homogenes Gefüge. Und bei denen läuft es.
Also völlig unverständlich, wie du jetzt über die besten Spieler sprechen kannst. Und Daily Syncraven, wo wir natürlich alle wussten, dass Leverkusen den dorthin verkauft hat. Genau, war sogar verkauft. Ich habe kurz überlegt, ob es eine Laie war. Daily Syncraven spielt natürlich auch bei Uli Las Palmas.
Und der stärkste Spieler, der laut Transfermarkt zum Beispiel, ist Maximo Perrone, der kommt von Manchester City, ist 20-jähriger Argentinier, spielt wenig. Und wenn er spielt, spielt er nicht sehr gut. Also auch da spricht das eigentlich eher für die Mannschaft oder für die Eigengewächse, die Lala Las Palmas selber hat, die im Moment dem Argentinier die Startelfen vermiesen. Ich glaube, dass Man City ihn auch dahin verliehen hat, damit er im Spielpraxis sammelt, da hat er im Moment noch nicht so viel bekommen. Aber er ist, wie gesagt, mit Abstand der wertvollste Spieler, den Las Palmas hat. Aber er ist noch nicht so wirklich angekommen, genauso wenig wie Sincrao, der auch zwar seine Einsätze bekommt, aber nicht zum Stammpersonal gehört.
Und weil du jetzt schon auf die Zweitligasaison von Las Palmas referiert hast, was ist denn das für ein Verein, quasi so im Gesamtgefüge des spanischen Fußballs? Also dass die jetzt auf Rang 8 stehen, das ist natürlich überraschend. Das ist ja klar, dass sie nicht so viel eingekauft haben. Das spricht ja, würde ich jetzt sagen, aus Entfernung schon dafür, dass sie quasi realistisch daran rangehen, dass sie quasi eher so –sie waren ja auch schon häufiger in der ersten Liga –Fahrstuhlmannschaft. Trifft es das richtig oder wo würdest du Las Palmas einordnen?
Ja, Fahrstuhlmannschaft trifft es ganz gut. Es gibt zwei große Klubs auf den Kanaren. Das ist eben Las Palmas und dann Tenerife. Kennt man noch, vielleicht früher hat mal Heintjes trainiert, auch mal Bernd Kraus und so weiter. Aber bei Tenerife läuft es in den letzten Jahren nicht mehr so gut. Die waren schon sehr, sehr lange nicht mehr in der ersten Liga. Und Las Palmas ist eher die Mannschaft, die es Fahrstuhlmäßig immer wieder schafft, nach oben und nach unten zu kommen. Es ist natürlich so, dass das Potenzial nicht so riesengroß ist. Du bist ja von den Kanaren auch erstmal noch mal ein paar Stunden weg vom Festland, bist ja eigentlich so halb in Afrika. Deswegen ist es auch nicht so einfach, glaube ich, sich dort etwas Größeres aufzubauen. Umso wichtiger ist es eigentlich, dort auf die Eigengewächse zu setzen, dort eine gute Nachwuchsarbeit zu machen. Die haben eine tolle eigene Sportstadt vor wenigen Jahren, drei, vier Jahren, eröffnet. Und ja, da sind wirklich hervorragende Bedingungen für Spieler, die dann Las Palmas eventuell dann maximal als Sprungbrett nutzen können, wie ich finde dann, wenn es dann zu größeren Teams geht. Aber wie gesagt, sie haben eine tolle Fußballkultur da und vor allen Dingen eine sehr, sehr offensive und es ist eine dieser Mannschaften, die lieber 4-3 gewinnt als 1-0 zum Beispiel.
Haben auch schon gegen Atletico 2 zu 1 gewonnen. Ansonsten natürlich, falls ihr es nicht mitbekommen habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, Girona weiter ganz, ganz vorne haben auch gegen Barca jetzt gewonnen. Das haben wir ja quasi angekündigt in der letzten Ligatur. Da hat es ja Alex Treuker schon mal mit der Sinnkrise Barca vor den entscheidenden Spielen angesprochen und Las Palmas dann eben mit 24 Punkten auf Rang 8 aktuell hat man damit 14 Punkte Vorsprung auf den ersten Abstiegsplatz und fünf Punkte rein theoretisch zum internationalen Geschäft. Wer weiß, wie weit das noch geht. Sehr, sehr schön, mal was von Las Palmas zu hören. Dann lasst uns in die Premier League wechseln. Uli, da ist auch so einiges passiert. Ich bin gespannt, ehrlich gesagt, was du dir herauskreist. Worüber magst du gerne als erstes sprechen?
Du weißt ja, ich nehme immer ein positives und ein negatives Thema mit. Ich möchte aber nicht mehr über Manchester United reden, weil ich hab's einfach dick. Ich glaube, das ist auch relativ schnell erzählt. Deswegen fange ich einfach mal an mit dem negativen Thema und nehme vorweg, es sind heute zwei Teams, mit denen man normalerweise nicht so viel zu tun hat. Ich gehe mal zu Crystal Palace. Hintergrund ist derjenige, dass Crystal Palace im Moment nur ein Spiel in den letzten neun gewonnen hat. Das ist jetzt aber noch nicht mal so überraschend, sondern es geht in erster Linie darum, dass Roy Hodgson, der ist inzwischen 76, als einer von Crystal Palace, der ist in Croydon geboren und war ein lebenslanger Fan und hat sich auch in den letzten Jahren einfach einen wahnsinnigen Kredit erarbeitet, weil er sie permanent drin gehalten hat. Der hat sich jetzt ein paar Mal nach Spielen etwas impulsiver geäußert, als man es von ihm kennt. Zuletzt hat er nach dem Mittwochs-Spiel auch richtige Buhrrufe hervorgerufen und dann vor allen Dingen noch mal die Wut auf sich gezogen, weil er gesagt hat, die Fans haben uns sozusagen geschadet, mit dem, was er gemacht hat davor. Im selben Monat hat er sich schon zwei Mal entschuldigen müssen, weil er einmal gesagt hat, nachdem die jungen Spieler reingekommen sind, dann sind wir halt viel schlechter geworden, tatsächlich. Dann hat er sich dann auch dafür entschuldigt. Und noch ein weiteres Mal, es ist ein wenig seltsam, wie Roy Hodgson im Moment kommuniziert. Und trotzdem war es gegen Liverpool ganz okay, was sie am Wochenende gemacht haben. Da sahen sie bis zur 80. Minute in etwa so aus, als könnten sie das Spiel gewinnen, wenigstens aber einen Punkt holen. Alles in allem ist aber die Truppe schon fast leblos. Es ist oft echt langweilig. Und wenn man sich so den Kader mal anguckt, dann kann man nicht recht verstehen, was die Ideen dahinter sind. Da sind wenige Transfers gemacht worden. Wilfrid Zaha ist ja im Sommer gegangen, den hätten sie gerne behalten, aber das ist nicht möglich gewesen. Und über den lief wahnsinnig viel. Die Nutzungsrate war schon sehr, sehr hoch. Und den hat man ihnen eigentlich nicht ersetzt. Da hat man den Jungen França geholt. Das war einer von denen, von dem Hodgson sagte, nachdem er reinkam, hat er sie schlechter gemacht. Und ansonsten nicht viel. Wir haben ernsthaft nicht viel auf dem Transfermarkt gemacht, außer einen verletzten Torwart für 20 Millionen zu holen. Und das ist die einzige Position, auf der sie ziemlich sicher gar keine Probleme haben. Jetzt ist natürlich Teil der Wahrheit auch, dass Ebrece Ese und Michael Olise verletzt sind. Zusammen sind sie nur 72 Minuten auf dem Feld gestanden. Das sind diejenigen, die das Umschaltsystem von Roy Hodgson laufen können. Die sind wirklich auch kreativ. Die können mal für so ein wenig Entlastung sorgen. Die fehlen natürlich. Dann haben sie nicht allzu schnelle Spieler, die dann die Positionen übernehmen. Jordan Ayuh als Beispiel. Sodass im Moment das Schlimmste aus allen Feldern zusammenkommt für Crystal Palace. Und dass man sie im Moment einfach schwierig anschauen kann.
Und wie heike würdest du die Lage dort einschätzen? Also Crystal Palace ist seit 2013, 2014 jetzt konstant in der Premier League. Aktuell liegt man in der Tabelle noch nicht auf einem Abstiegsplatz. Aber man hat jetzt auch nur noch –na gut, es sind immerhin 7 Punkte, sehe ich gerade. Da gibt es ja dann doch eine kleine Lücke. Stimmt, die hat sich ja gebildet in den letzten beiden Spieltagen. Also muss man da jetzt grundsätzliche Diskussionen anstrengen bei Crystal? Oder ist das eben einfach so eine –bei Crystal, bei Crystal Palace. Oder ist das jetzt so eine Delle, die vielleicht auch damit zu tun hat, dass dann vielleicht dann doch die Zeit von Roy Hodgson langsam vorbei sein könnte?
Ja, die war ja schon mal vorbei. Dann haben sie ihn doch wieder verpflichtet. Ja, das hat wieder funktioniert. Deswegen ist sie ja doch immer nie vorbei. Ich glaube, das sollten sie irgendwann mal ernsthaft angehen mit einem langfristigeren Plan als den, den sie haben. Ich habe genau die Frage auch gestellt, so im Umfeld. Habt ihr Angst, abzusteigen? Und dann haben sie gesagt, mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit werden sich drei Dürmeren finden. Das ist uns schon klar. Aber es geht jetzt auch ein wenig um die Art und Weise, die sie an den Tag legen. Da sind ein paar Spieler drin, die definitiv dann zum Abverkauf stünden. Also Mark Geyhi in der Verteidigung. Ich glaube auch, dass die auch immer anders sind, das nicht lange mitmachen würden. Mitchell Niemals als Linksverteidiger. Die genannten Esay und Ulisse, das sind so die, die rausstechen. Und wenn man dann aber wieder keinen Plan parat hat, die entsprechend zu ersetzen, dann wird es furchtbar. Also die haben ein paar Spieler verpflichtet, die halt vorne und hinten nicht funktionieren. Ahamada, das war mit die bodenlosesten 20 Minuten, die ich von dem Spieler gesehen habe gegen Liverpool am Samstag. Und von denen haben sie sich jetzt ein paar Transfers geleistet, und ich denke, okay, das funktioniert ja vorne und hinten nicht.
Ach, das ist ja auch Verschwendung, Ahamada. Beim VfB war er so wichtig. Ich meine nicht, dass sie es gerade bräuchten. Aber gut so ist das. Weil jetzt, da habe ich jetzt in den letzten Tagen viel drüber nachgedacht, deswegen stelle ich die Frage Uli, und zwar nach der, wie gerne guckt man Spiele von Crystal Palace? Weil jetzt zum einen eben gerade Investorenanstieg in der DFL, und da wird eben viel über Attraktivität der Bundesliga gesprochen, aber auch, es gibt ja den neuen TV-Deal für die Premier League, der mal wieder Rekordzahlen auflegt, aber man hat das unter anderem damit erreicht, dass jetzt mehr Spiele gezeigt werden. Es ist ja immer noch nicht so, dass es alle Spiele zu sehen gibt der Premier League. Wie gerne guckt man Crystal Palace gerade zu? Wo würdest du das denn einsortieren? Du kennst dich ja auch in der Bundesliga gut aus.
Ja, also als ich das gesehen habe, habe ich schon mir gedacht, was habe ich eigentlich getan. Es gab eine Zeit unter Patrick Vieira, wo sie mit die aufregendsten jungen Spieler hatten, die es gibt. Es gab auch eine Zeit unter Roy Hodgson, wo ich letztes Jahr gesagt habe, ja, okay, das ist halt dreckiger Umschaltfußball, aber okay, gut, ist in Ordnung für mich. Aber im Moment, es macht keinen Spaß. Es ist echt ein lebloses Team, sozusagen. Und selbst diejenigen, die nach Athletik aussehen, sehen irgendwie gebremst aus, sodass das wahrscheinlich im Moment, also es gibt ein paar Teams, die sind jetzt nicht looten als Beispiel, ist jetzt nicht der Wahnsinn, sich anzugucken, aber da lebt halt alles. Mit dem kann ich dann leben. Aber mit dem Potenzial, was da sein sollte bei Crystal Palace, ist es schon sehr, sehr wenig, muss ich sagen.
Es ist einfach Verschwendung, ja, so kann man es glaube ich auf einen Punkt bringen. Vier Siege, vier Unentschieden, acht Niederlagen, 15 Tore erst in 16 Partien erzielt. Damit ist man nicht der schlechteste Angriff dieser Liga, aber es gibt da schon einen deutlichen Abfall. Also man ist da auf einer Ebene mit Nottingham, mit Luthen, mit Burnley und nur Sheffield ist noch schlechter. Und über Sheffield haben wir ja auch schon mal hier gesprochen in der Ligatur. Da sind ja die Maßstäbe ganz andere. Also Crystal Palace, oder wie ich sie gerne nenne, Crystal –das wird sich jetzt bestimmt durchsetzen als neue Spitzname –steht nicht so gut da. Dann springen wir mal in die Serie A. Und ja, da ist die Frage, mit welchen deinen Themen merkst du denn da anfangen? Was passt jetzt gut?
Ja, fangen wir mal mit der Aktualität an, würde ich sagen. Ich habe mir Milan rausgegriffen, da sind wir dann am Champions League Mittwochabend. Wer es nicht mitbekommen hat, Milan hat in New Castle gewonnen, aber ist nicht ins Achtelfinale eingezogen, sondern haben dadurch jetzt zumindest noch Minimumziel die Europa League. Weitere Teilnahme garantiert. Aber ich habe mir Milan rausgepickt, weil so ein bisschen –ich würde mal den Titel drüber setzen –die verpassten Chancen. Wenn man sich die Gruppenphase von Milan anschaut, dann war klar, gestern waren sie abhängig von Dortmund und Dortmund hätte gewinnen müssen. Dortmund hat nicht geliefert. Dementsprechend ist das Problem logisch nicht gestern bei Milan entstanden, sondern da gibt es eine ganze Reihe. Am meisten sticht das erste Heimspiel gegen Newcastle heraus. Da haben sie Newcastle an die Wand gespielt, aber die Bude nicht gemacht. Am Ende war es 0-0 und genau die Punkte haben im Prinzip gefehlt. Aber es waren mehrere Spiele. Auch das letzte gegen Dortmund zu Hause war eine riesen Chance, wo sie nicht gut gespielt haben, wo sie verloren haben. Auch wieder Thema verpasste Chancen. Es gab den frühen Elfmeter von Girouda. Wenn er den rein macht, gehen sie in Führung. Dann könnte Dortmund nicht mehr kurz darauf per Elfmeter in Führung gehen und dann abwarten, spielen und umschalten. Es hat so ein bisschen reingepasst, dass es jetzt schon ein bitterer Beigeschmack für Milan ist, dass sie es nicht ins Achtelfinale geschafft haben, obwohl sie es eigentlich auch in dieser sehr schwierigen Gruppe mehr als möglich gewesen wäre. Dementsprechend ist es so ein bisschen die Gemengelage, kommen wir jetzt auf die Liga. Milan ist im Moment so ein bisschen, du weißt nicht immer genau, was du von ihnen kriegst. Sie haben ja am Wochenende vor dem Newcastle-Spiel gegen Atalanta in Bergamo gespielt, haben sie verloren, was jetzt kein Beinbruch ist. Gegen Atalanta kannst du immer verlieren. Aber wenn man sich jetzt halt ansieht tabellarisch, sie haben halt mittlerweile neun Punkte Rückstand auf Milan, auf Inter und neun Punkte auf ein so stabiles, so sicheres Inter. Ja, ich weiß, die Saison ist noch lang, aber das ist schon ein Riesenbrett. Plus ist da ja nicht nur Inter allein, sondern Juve ist da auch vorne weg, sieben Punkte weg. Also sie hängen so ein bisschen hinten dran. Sie haben ein kleines Polster auf Platz vier, wo wirklich ein sehr, sehr enges Rennen ist. Aber sie haben jetzt wirklich den Anschluss an Inter und Juve verloren. Was auch, da kommen wir wieder zum Thema, daran hängt, wo man auch die Klammer zur Champions League schließen kann, weil sie oft die großen Spiele verlieren. Sie haben nämlich dieses Dortmund-Heimspiel verloren, was sie nicht verlieren hätten dürfen. Da hätte eine Punkte auch schon gereicht, um weiterzukommen. Sie haben jetzt gegen Atalanta verloren, sie haben gegen Inter verloren, sie haben gegen Juve verloren. Also das ist so eine Gemengelage, wo es ein bisschen schwierig ist einzubauen. Vor allen Dingen, weil ja am Saisonstart wahnsinnig viel Euphorie da war. Da haben wir auch zu Recht darüber geredet, weil eben diese Restrukturierung. Sie haben ja Tonale im Sommer für sehr viel Geld verkauft und haben dann über dieses Geld eigentlich sehr gut Leute geholt. Reinders, Loftusci, Chimusa, Chukwese. Sie haben sich ein bisschen breiter aufgestellt. Und das hat am Anfang wirklich auch von Art und Weise sehr, sehr, sehr gut funktioniert. Aber da ist jetzt in den letzten Wochen so ein bisschen Rollercoaster mäßig reingekommen. Es ist halt nicht die Konstanz da und ein Riesenthema, das wir uns ansprechen müssen. Und da geht es dann schon halt auch um den Trainer-Stuff, sage ich mal. Sie haben unfassbar viele Verletzte. Sie haben 25 Verletzte. Bitte was? Das ist schon, finde ich, eine beeindruckende Zahl. Aber der zweite Teil der Zahl ist noch beeindruckender. 18 dieser 25 sind muskuläre Verletzungen. Und da ist es dann logischerweise schon, da muss man dann schon drauf schauen, was da in der täglichen Arbeit, ob da halt vielleicht nicht immer die richtigen Impulse gesetzt werden. Das jüngste Beispiel war ja Malik Dschau, der gegen Dortmund raus musste, muskulär, mehrere Wochen jetzt auch bis ins neue Jahr fehlen wird. Deswegen hat jetzt Milan der einzige gelernte Innenverteidiger, den sie noch haben, ist Tomori. Deswegen hat jetzt Theo Hernandez drei-, viermal Innenverteidiger gespielt. Sie haben keinen mehr, also es ist wirklich keiner mehr da, weil auch Kia verletzt ist, weil auch Kalulo verletzt ist, lange ausfällt und wie gesagt, also 18 muskuläre Verletzungen, da muss man dann logisch schon die Frage stellen, ob da halt vielleicht nicht systematisch auch ein bisschen was, ja, nicht richtig läuft in der Trainingssteuerung.
Aber das ist jetzt quasi über den Verlauf der Saison, also nicht jetzt gerade 25. Ich sehe, da wird der FC Bayern auf dem Winter-Transfermarkt vielleicht mindestens einen Konkurrenten um ihn verteidigen haben, was?
Ja, genau, deswegen auch gutes Anspruchs. Das ist ein kleiner Blick in den Winter. Es scheint sich einiges zu tun, dass Milan da probiert, was zu machen, und zwar nicht nur innenverteidigermäßig, sondern auch mittelstürmermäßig, denn auch das ist jetzt so eine Position. Olivier Giroud ist klar gesetzt, keine Frage, aber Olivier Giroud ist halt 37 und alle drei Tage die wichtigen Spiele, den Rhythmus, ist halt für ihn nicht mehr so einfach. Da wurde ja Iovic geholt. Iovic muss man jetzt zuletzt fairerweise sagen, hat jetzt zweimal in der Liga getroffen, hat auch gestern das Siegtor vorbereitet in Newcastle. Also er kommt so langsam, aber die ersten Wochen, Monate war Iovic –also da kam nichts, so wie bei Rean, so genau wie man ihn von –wie man die letzten Jahre eigentlich von Iovic kannte, bis auf eine kleine Ausnahme bei der Fiorentina, da hat er eine kurze Phase gehabt, aber eben, es passt da rein und dementsprechend wird jetzt der Name Jonathan David von Lille, der war schon im Sommer ein Riesenthema, da war er zu teuer für Milan, also der geistert. Achtung, alle VHFP-Fans, Milan war jetzt mehrfach in Stuttgart, hat sich mal Herben Girassi ein bisschen näher angeschaut, überraschenderweise weiß Milan auch um die Klausel, die da liegt, also Girassi ist wohl ein Thema, und dann aber auch ganz klar eben Innenverteidiger, weil sie haben keine Innenverteidiger mehr. Aber die Bereitschaft scheint wohl da zu sein von Seiten der amerikanischen Eigentümer im Winter nachzulegen.
Ich denke mal, im Winter wird einiges passieren, allgemein auch in Spanien ist es so, dass ganz viele Teams erhebliche Verletzungsprobleme haben, auch ganz viele muskuläre Geschichten übrigens. Ich denke, dass allgemein die Belastung der Spieler wahrscheinlich viel zu hoch geworden ist.
Da lese ich auch drauf auf.
Die WM in Katar hat wahrscheinlich auch nicht so wirklich geholfen, da irgendwie in einem Rhythmus zu bleiben, in einem Flow zu bleiben. Alle Mannschaften, oder was heißt alle, ist vielleicht übertrieben, aber viele Mannschaften haben erhebliche Probleme, viele Verletzte und jeder muss am Transfermarkt fast irgendwas machen. Also es wird sehr spannend, es wird ein Wett bieten werden für die guten, für die goldenen Eier sozusagen und ich glaube, das wird fast noch aufregender als die Sommertransferperiode.
Oh Gott, bitte nicht. Nein, oh nein, ich ertrag das nicht schon wieder.
Ja, aber es ist bei Fabian gut, dass er es anspricht, der Correre della Sera, also einer der renommiertesten Tageszeitungen in Italien. Sie haben vor kurzem eine europaweite Studie durchgeführt und da haben sie auch, ich glaube, die Premier League war, das war glaube ich, die Geschichte kam Ende November und da war die Premier League, glaube ich, da waren es bis zu dem Zeitpunkt irgendwie 70 muskuläre Verletzungen in der Serie A waren es 65, La Liga war auch um den Dreh rum. Also es ist ein Problem, das logischerweise nicht nur in Italien besteht, sondern eben wirklich die Top-Ligen alle betrifft, dass eben die Belastung für die Spieler, dass jetzt auch so langsam die Rechnung dafür kommt, das was Fabian schon gesagt hat, Wermink hat da, all diese Geschichten und im Moment strahlt es wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr deutlich aus.
Ja und die Ironie darin ist, dass ja Milan mit dem Milan Lab das 2008 oder irgendwie so eingeführt wurde. Eigentlich damals, also gerade das Thema Belastungssteuerung und quasi laufend Laktatteste und andere Dinge zu machen, um eben quasi so etwas vorzubeugen. Da war Milan mal maßgebend. Natürlich hat sich da die Zeit auch verändert, aber trotzdem, das ist natürlich die kleine Fußnote, die da noch dran hängen.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber letzter Punkt zum Abschluss, Slata Nibirujevic ist zurück bei Milan. Nicht mehr als Spieler, wäre das jetzt vielleicht noch kurz gedacht. Sondern ich glaube, heute ist sogar sein erster offizieller Tag als Berater von Giare Cardinale, vom Präsidenten. Die letzten Wochen, Monate gab es da Gespräche. Klar, er wird irgendwie kommen. Die Frage war, wie bauen sie ihn ein? Jetzt ist er Berater des Präsidenten. Ja, genau, mal schauen. Slata Nibirujevic hat jetzt wirklich auch wieder sozusagen eine offizielle Rolle. Mal schauen, wie genau die ausgestaltet wird. Aber Fakt ist, er ist wieder am Team dran. Wird so ein bisschen Pindeglied zwischen Pioli und Vereinsführung sein, auch mit den Spielern logischerweise mit seiner Aura versuchen, da das einzubringen. Mal schauen. Es gibt in Italien auch ein paar kritische Stimmen, die das so ein bisschen gemeint haben, womöglich untergräbt er dadurch auch ein bisschen die Autorität von Pioli. Eigentlich waren Pioli und Ibrahimovic immer sehr eng, sehr emotional miteinander. Pioli, glaube ich, kann das einordnen. Ibrahimovic, mal schauen, ob er sich einordnen kann. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine Geschichte, die sich angedeutet hat und die jetzt einfach schwarz auf weiß, offiziell ist.
Und wir haben den Folgentitel gefunden. Ibrahimovic macht den Samme. Da habe ich sie doch alle wieder reingezogen in diese Ligatur und 25 Minuten lang haben sie sich gefragt, was zur Hölle und jetzt endlich wissen sie, ja gut, das hat sich ja wirklich nicht gelohnt. Aber wir werden es wettmachen. Mit dem zweiten Thema aus La Liga. Denn auch da wird uns Fabian so ein bisschen überraschen. Wir haben über Real Sociedad schon mal gesprochen. Die sind ja auch immer mal wieder so ein bisschen aufgepoppt. Sie stehen aktuell auf Rang 6. Punktgleich mit Athletic Bilbao. Das heißt aktuell im internationalen Geschäft direkt dran. Und vor allem, ich sehe Fabian erst drei Niederlagen, 18 Gegentore. Das scheint mir eine sehr stabile Mannschaft zu sein.
Absolut und Surprise, Surprise. Ich spreche über eine baskische Mannschaft, kommt ja auch selten vor bei mir. Aber es bietet sich tatsächlich an, weil wir hatten ja gerade den Champions League Mittwochabend schon angedeutet. Real Sociedad hat ein 0 zu 0 bei Inter Mailand geholt. Es ist auch keine Laufkundschaft, wie die gesamten Gegner in der Champions League waren für San Sebastian mit Benfica Lissabon und auch Raval Salzburg –nein, Red Bull Salzburg natürlich. Und sind dort Gruppenärzte geworden. Das war jetzt nicht unbedingt zu erwarten gewesen. Und das spricht eigentlich genau für das, was du gerade gesagt hast, Max. Die Mannschaft ist unwahrscheinlich stabil geworden. Und der Imanol Aguasil, den Trainer haben wir auch schon oft angesprochen, in San Sebastian arbeiten sie seit ein paar Jahren richtig eng zusammen. Ich habe vor kurzem ein ausführlicheres Interview in Spanien mit Xavi Alonso, der auch noch sehr verbunden ist mit seinem Heimatclub. Und der genau das auch heraus gearbeitet oder herausgestochen hat, dass dort ein ganz großes Gemeinschaftsgefüge aufgebaut worden ist. Von der Vereinsführung her, über die Trainer, viele Talente, die man früher, baskische Talente, die man früher an Athletik will bauen, sowieso verloren hatte, weil das eben der baskische Club ist, bleiben jetzt doch eher in San Sebastian, weil man dort einfach irgendwie, ja, so ein Gemeinschaftsgefühl entwickelt hat. Man spielt einen attraktiven Fußball, wie ich finde, mit hohem Dressing, mit schon offensiver Ausrichtung. Das wird so durchgeführt durch die unteren Kategorien, also in die Jugendmannschaften, da wird früh schon dieses System von Aguasil quasi einstudiert. Es ist auch so, dass die Hälfte der Mannschaft, würde ich sagen, aus der eigenen Jugend kommt bzw. schon eben länger bei San Sebastian spielt. Und man hat auch sehr ordentliche Neuverpflichtungen gemacht, einfach im Sommer. Und ja, dementsprechend haben sie tatsächlich an Stabilität dazugewonnen. Sie waren in den letzten Jahren auch schon sehr erfolgreich, aber dieses Jahr sind sie noch ein Stück weit stabiler. Und der beste Beweis ist, glaube ich, der Sieg der Gruppenphase in der Champions League.
Ja, das ist halt wirklich, das glaube ich, wo auch so manch andere das gesehen hat. Und ich muss sagen, das letzte Spiel war jetzt ja in Mailand bei Inter. Und Inter musste es gewinnen. Dann ist man Gruppen-Erster, geht damit gewissen Gegnern aus dem Weg. Und Inter ist ja gerade aktuell auch die beste Mannschaft der Serie A, gemeinsam mit Juve. Ich bin fest davon ausgegangen, naja, das wird schon so ein 1 zu 0 werden. Oder ein 2 zu 1, aber Real hat sie richtig dich gemacht letztlich. Also die sind kaum vorgekommen in der Konferenz, die ich geguckt habe.
Ja, ist witzig, deswegen ich wollte jetzt Fabian auch darauf ansprechen. Absolut, also dass Sociedad da als Gruppensieger rausgeht. Ganz, ganz großes Kino und da auch in San Siro gegen Inter nicht zu verlieren, keine Frage. Nur das Witzige, weil du gerade sagt hast, du hast erwartet, dass Inter 1 zu 0 gewinnt. Man kann ja ganz oft auch erwarten, dass Sociedad 1 zu 0 gewinnt. Und für mich war jetzt, weil ich sie halt mal 90 Minuten wirklich gesehen habe, wollte ich in Fabian mal fragen. Also sie tun sich schon, oder? Also gerade letzte Saison glaube ich, hatten sie sehr viele 1 zu 0 Siege. Ich glaube in der ersten Saison auch. Also sie sind stabil, aber auch, obwohl sie wahnsinnig viel Ballbesitz haben. Gegen Inter hatten sie in der ersten Halbzeit mal phasenweise 80 Prozent. Aber sie hatten keinen einzigen Schuss aufs Tor. Also es ist schon oft, es ist sehr viel Ballbesitz. Keine Frage. Und gerade auch das Pressing, das Fabian angesprochen hat, das war auch beeindruckend, weil sie wirklich in den ersten Minuten hoch anlaufen und da wirklich Inter einige Probleme bereitet haben, aber dann halt im Spiel mit Ball. Jetzt klar muss man dazu sagen, Inter ist für mich eine der defensiv beststrukturiertesten Mannschaften Europas. Also Inter ist eben auch so eine Mannschaft, die kann sich auch mal bespielen lassen. Da werden die nicht verrückt. Aber ich wollte Fabian eben fragen, das ist ja schon auch ein bisschen in der DNA drin, oder sie tun sich dann schon manchmal auch ein bisschen schwer, aus all diesem Ballbesitz raus, dann aber auch gefährlich zu werden?
Absolut. Sie haben da im Abschluss große Probleme und suchen da eigentlich seit Jahren so nach dem Knipser vorne, der die Dinger macht, haben sich ja im Sommer verstärkt mit Omar Sadik, der war nigerianischer oder isnagranischer Nationalspieler, war bei Almeria richtig stark, hat die in die 1. Liga geballert und wurde europaweit nachgefragt. Dann hat er sicher das Kreuzband gerissen und der kommt jetzt gerade erst wieder, hat in der Liga in den letzten zwei Spielen zwei wahnsinnig krasse Tore gemacht, so irgendwie Fernschüsse aus 30 Metern in den Winkel, das war halt wirklich brutale Tore. Also der scheint jetzt endlich zu kommen. Dann hat er andere Silber geholt von Leipzig. Der war auch gleich verletzt, der kommt jetzt gerade auch erst wieder rein. Dann haben sie noch ein bisschen Verletzungspech, auch auf der Flügelstürmerposition. Da hatten sie mit Barenetéa ein sehr gutes Eingewächs, der auch sehr torgefährlich war. Im Moment läuft es richtig gut, wie Christian gesagt hat, bis ins letzte Drittel rein. Wenn man im Strafraum mal reingetribbelt ist, dann fehlen dann die Ideen oder der letzte Pass oder der Abschluss. Da müssen sie mit Sicherheit noch dran arbeiten. Sie haben das Positive, dass sie jetzt auch defensiv einfach so stabil geworden sind mit Robin Le Mans, der spanische Nationalspieler, hinten drinnen, mit Supermendi, der im defensiven Mittelfeld unwahrscheinlich viel abräumt, der auch hoch gehandelt wird bei vielen Top-Klubs in Spanien, der aber auch sich entschieden hat, erst mal noch bei San Sebastian zu bleiben. Die haben einen sehr guten Außenverteidiger geholt, wie ich finde, aus Frankreich, Trauré, der unwahrscheinlich stark spielt, finde ich, als rechter Außenverteidiger. Ich weiß nicht, wo er gestern gespielt hat, ab und zu wird auch links eingesetzt. Dann haben sie auch von Arsenal Eimann geholt, der zwar viel verletzt ist, aber wenn er spielt, finde ich, dann sieht man schon, was er drauf hat. Jetzt muss ich mal versuchen, den richtig auszusprechen. Uli, du sagst mir, wenn ich es falsch mache, er ist ja schon der Kyriam Tierney. Der ist ja auch ein Riesentalent aus Arsenal. Leider immer verletzt, bei San Sebastian leider auch oft verletzt. Aber jetzt spielt er gerade wieder und finde ich auch richtig stark, wenn er dann spielt.
Ich habe nichts zu beantworten.
Also besser wird es nicht. Und ich stelle fest, du hast heute, obwohl wir heute nicht über Real und Barca geredet haben, über Ballbesitzteams gesprochen. In der Statistik La Liga, Las Palmas auf Rang 2, zwischen Barca auf Rang 1 und Real Madrid auf 3 und Real Sociedad dann auf Rang 6 hinter Girona und Sevilla. Also Sevilla ist vielleicht der eine, der einen da überrascht. Aber ansonsten interessant.
Also richtig stark ist zusammengewachsen. Und die Frage bei Real Sociedad wird dann immer sein, am Ende der Saison, welche Spieler können sie halten und wie wird es weitergehen?
Ich persönlich, also das ist jetzt ganz, ganz, ganz subjektiv und kommt tief aus meiner Kindheit. Aber ich liebe es, wenn Teams, die so eine Fahne im Logo haben, wenn die Erfolg haben, fand ich immer toll.
Ja, und ich finde noch eins hat vielleicht von mir dazu. Allein die Entwicklung, allein das Real Sociedad in die Champions League gekommen ist. Ich qualifizierte da letztes Jahr. Und jetzt kommst du aus der Gruppe, aus Gruppen Top 4, auch noch als Gruppen-Erster weiter. Entgehst damit wirklich vielen großen Namen. Das zeigt ja, dass die Entwicklung mehr als nachhaltig ist.
Gott sei Dank wird die Gruppenphase abgeschafft, dass solche Märchen nie wieder möglich sind. Dann wollen wir nochmal in die Premier League gucken. Uli, was hast du uns als zweites Thema mitgebracht?
Ja, jetzt sind wir dabei. Ich möchte heute, dass heute deine Server komplett explodieren. Ich könnte jetzt natürlich über Liverpool sprechen, Tabellenführer, Aston Villa. Das mach ich dann auch später noch. Aber ganz schnell. Ich hab mir mal Fulham ausgesucht. Hintergrund ist der, dass sie zweimal 5-0 in Folge gewonnen haben. Wahrscheinlich werden wir ansonsten nicht mehr allzu viel über Fulham sprechen. Deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, machen wir das mal, weil der Rest ist auch langweilig. Warum sie zweimal in Folge 5-0 gewonnen haben, kann ich dir nicht erklären. Das hab ich probiert, rauszufinden, ob sie irgendwas verändert haben. Ja, ein paar Spieler gewechselt. Tom Kerney in die Startformation, Thorsten Adrabayo in die Startformation, anstelle Tim Reams. Das heißt, etwas mehr Tempo möglicherweise. Kerney, der als Ballverteiler ganz okay aussah, aber eh schon immer ein wichtiger Bestandteil war, als Kapitän der Truppe, nur nie über 90 Minuten gespielt hat. Das war jetzt auch das erste Mal am vergangenen Spieltag. Raul Remenes, der ansatzweise wieder so aussieht, wie er einmal war, bevor er sich so schwer am Kopf verletzt hat bei den Wolves und danach einfach nie wieder der Gleiche war. Der hat jetzt ein paar Mal getroffen. Es ist immer noch nicht so, dass der jetzt über den Berg wäre. Soweit möchte ich nicht gehen. Aber nachdem vor der Länderspielpause schon so als kleines Sorgentind galt und man Markus Silva auch zurecht vorwerfen durfte, dass er manchmal ein bisschen stur ist, von hinten heraus spielend und gar nicht akzeptieren will, dass Mitrovic nicht mehr da ist und einfach das Spiel komplett simuliert, auch da nicht so richtig unterstützt worden mit Transfers. Im Gegenteil, Mitrovic einfach verkauft und dann ist ja egal, da wird schon irgendwas passieren. Und jetzt funktioniert es gerade, sagen wir mal, 5 Minuten Folge. Und deswegen seien die hier mal genannt.
Gegen Nottingham und gegen West Ham. Aber wie kannst du denn über die wichtigsten Spieler Vollheims sprechen, ohne die Holding Six Palinja anzusprechen?
Das tut mir sehr leid. Palinja ist ein fantastischer, wichtiger Spieler für Vollheim. Er war erstaunlicherweise ein paar Mal öfter verletzt oder nicht dabei. In der Saison im Vergleich zu den Vorjahren. Oder im Vorjahr vor allen Dingen. Ist ja noch nicht so viel länger da. Aber jetzt zum Beispiel am Wochenende auch wieder gespielt. Sodass man sich auch einen Spielertypen wie Tom Kerney, der eigentlich im Herzen Zehner ist, leisten kann neben ihm. Das ist schon nicht ganz unwichtig. Und man merkt immer, wenn Palinja drauf ist, dann ist Vollheim ein bisschen besser. Ich sage immer in unserem Podcast, das ist ein Team, das die Basics sehr gut machen muss, um erfolgreich zu sein. Oder zumindest nicht unerfolgreich. Und Palinja ist eigentlich das Paradebeispiel dafür. Von dem kriegst du selten eine schlechte Leistung.
Sehr schön. Hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass wir hier mit Vollheim noch ums Eck kommen in dieser Ligatur. Aber ich freue mich dann umso mehr auf die Awards. Zu denen kommen wir nämlich jetzt. Das heißt, wir wollen MVP, Angst an Hero und Moment des Spieltags oder der letzten Wochen hören. Fabian, du darfst...
Oder Max, wollen wir auch noch über Serie A, das Zweite, sprechen?
Guck mal, weil du dich vorhin noch mal entviewtet hast, dachte ich mir, ach ja, vielleicht...
Ich bin raus, oder wie?
Nee, deswegen dachte ich irgendwie, das war in meinem Kopf... Stimmt, wir haben ja noch...
Ich habe noch was Nettes mitgebracht.
Aber wäre es nicht total witzig gewesen, wenn dieses Thema quasi in der Nachspielzeit dieses Podcasts gekommen wäre? Aber jetzt... Ja, tun wir einfach so, als hätte ich das geplant.
Genau. Ja, nehmen wir uns Kaljari mal zu Herzen. Wir haben ja heute mal ein paar Vereine, die jetzt relativ selten in Erscheinung treten. Und da machen wir das auch sehr gerne mit Kaljari, mit der Überschrift Last Minute Kaljari. Also, Kaljari, die Geschichte fangen wir am Wochenende an. Das ist der Aufhänger. Kaljari Heimspiel spielt gegen Sassuolo, liegt 0-1 zurück bis zur 94. Minute. Und am Spielende gewinnt Kaljari 2-1, weil La Padula eben dieser 94. das 1-1 macht und Leonardo Pavolette in der 99. das 2-1. So, das alleine reicht jetzt logischerweise noch nicht, um in die Ligatur aufgenommen zu werden. Aber das Besondere ist, Kaljari hat das jetzt schon mehrfach gemacht. Und Kaljari kommt –also Kaljari ist ein Aufsteiger, trainiert von Sir Claudio Ranieri, der wirklich auch –das ist schon mal eine schöne Geschichte –der gesagt hat, Kaljari wird seine letzte Trainerstation, also Clubstation sein. Ranieri ist mittlerweile 72. Und warum ist das besonders? Weil Kaljari seine erste Profi-Trainerstation war im fernen Jahr 1988. Also er wollte immer, hat immer gesagt, er möchte nochmal auf Kaljari, auf Sardinien in Kaljari, für diesen Club, wo alles für ihn begann, sozusagen arbeiten. Und hat auch jetzt vor ein paar Wochen –das war eine schöne Szene, weil Ranieri logisch mit seiner Art auch in Italien immer noch als Elder Statesman, auch ein bisschen der Trainer gilt. Da war gerade die Geschichte, dass Mancini sich von der Nationalmannschaft verabschiedet hatte. Wir wissen alle Richtung Saudi-Arabien. Und da wurde halt auch Ranieri gefragt, ob für ihn sowas auch in Frage käme. Er meinte, Kaljer wird sicher sein letzter Club sein. Er hat gesagt, vielleicht auch noch eine Nationalmannschaft, wenn das Spannende dabei ist. Und dann kam die Frage, wer dann vielleicht das Saudi-Arabische Raum was für ihn? Er hat gesagt, never ever. Für ihn steht die Motivation oder die Idee im Vordergrund nicht das Geld. Und das logischerweise kam dann sehr gut in Italien an, weil gerade die Geschichte mit Mancini zum Tragen kam. Also so viel zu Ranieri. Das Besondere an Kalieri, sie haben die ersten neun Spieltage kein einziges Spiel gewonnen. Also sie steckten von Anfang an wirklich ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz hinten drin. Und dann kam Spieltag 10, Duell mit Sassuolo, auch Aufsteiger. Und da lagen sie bis zur 74. Minute 0-3 zurück zu Hause. Endstand 4-3. Sie haben das Spiel noch gewonnen. Vielen Dank, dass du aufpasst. Genau, Frau Sinone, also Aufstiegskollege, also bis zur 74. Minute 0-3. Eines der legendärsten Comebacks der letzten Jahre in Italien. Auch da zwei Tore in der Nachspielzeit. Beide Tore wieder von Leonardo Pavoletti. Das ist ein Mittelstürmer, 35 Jahre, der logisch in Italien viel schon miterlebt hat, der meistens eher bei bisschen kleineren Vereinen war. Er hatte einmal vor sechs oder sieben Jahren war kurz bei Napoli. Das war so seine Chance, sich auch beim Großen zu zeigen. Er hat auch kurz Champions League gespielt. Er ist ein unfassbar kopfballstarker Spieler für mich, mit der besten Kopfballspieler der Liga, also bringt viel Füße mit. Er hat jetzt bei diesem legendären 4-3 gegen Frosinone beide Tore in der Nachspielzeit erzählt, zum 3-3 und zum 4-3. Und jetzt macht er eben in der 99. wieder das 2-1. Und das Besondere daran ist, Ranieri hat ihn dann wirklich danach sehr geadelt. Er hat gesagt, ich habe in meiner Karriere viele Champions trainiert, was man bei Ranieri durchaus einen Haken darunter setzen kann. Und er hat gesagt, Pavoletti passt echt in diese Reihe rein. Also von seiner Mentalität her ist es wahnsinnig wichtig für die Mannschaft. Er hat gesagt, er dosiert ihn auch ein bisschen, weil er ja mittlerweile 35 ist, aber das kommt ihm zu gut. Er kommt oft als Einwechslspieler, hat dann aber einen wahnsinnigen Impact auf die Mannschaft. Und das Besondere daran ist, ich habe mich dann so ein bisschen rein gefuchst und es ist eigentlich fast unglaublich, Paolo Lethe hat im letzten Jahr sechs Tore geschossen und fünf davon in der Nachspielzeit. Also irgendwann ist es dann vielleicht halt wirklich kein Zufall mehr, wenn das so oft passiert. Und die Geschichte, damit sie wirklich den ganzen Rahmen bekommt, ist, Kaljeri Aufsteiger, Kaljeri musste durch die Playoffs in der vergangenen Saison und die letzte Stufe war das Playoff-Endspiel gegen Bari. Also es war klar, Bari oder Kaljeri, einer steigt auf. Hinspiel in Sardinien, in Kaljeri ging unentschieden aus. Und damit war klar, Kaljeri musste gewinnen in Bari. Bis zur 94. Minute steht es 0-0. Den Rest der Geschichte kennt ihr wahrscheinlich. Ich spreche trotzdem aus, Paolo Lethe machte nach 94. ins 1-0. Also all das, was ich vorhin erzählt habe, konnte auch erst entstehen, weil Paolo Lethe in der Nachspielzeit war. Es ist wirklich eine emotionale Geschichte, weil Kaljeri ein Verein ist, der die Serie A schon so lange begleitet. Quasi wirklich ein Traditionsclub, der in den letzten Jahren immer wieder ein bisschen rauf und runter war, aber der immer so eine besondere Note reinbringt. Nicolo Barella kommt jetzt zum Beispiel aus Sardinien. Er hat bei Kaljeri seine ersten Schritte gemacht, bevor er ihn dann in Inter aus Festland geholt hat. Früher war es Gigi Riva, der legendäre italienische Stürmer, der Kaljeri nie verlassen hat, der Sardinien nie verlassen hat, obwohl Juve, Milan, Inter dem alle riesen Verträge hingelegt haben. Die Sardinien sind ja auch sehr eng verbunden mit ihrem Heimatland. Dementsprechend schwingt bei Kaljeri immer etwas Besonderes mit. Jetzt ist eben Ranieri da Trainer. Jetzt ist es eine Mannschaft, die am Anfang überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat. Sie haben jetzt mittlerweile 13 Punkte. Sie sind nicht mehr auf dem Abstiegsplatz. Klar, es ist extrem eng da hinten. Aber noch mal zur Erinnerung, nach neun Spieltagen hatten sie drei oder vier Punkte. Viele dieser Punkte haben sie in den letzten Wochen geholt. Neben Pavoletti auch Lappadula muss man nennen. Das war der Aufstiegsstürmer, der wahnsinnig oft getroffen hat. Der war auch lange verletzt. Kaljeri, der Verein, ist ruhigeblieben. Ranjer hat auch gesagt, wenn Lappadula wieder da ist, wenn Pavoletti da ist, dann kommen wir so langsam. Und genau so ist es. Sie sind ruhigeblieben, sind nicht hektisch geworden und werden sicherlich bis zum Ende gegen den Abstieg spielen müssen. Gar keine Frage. Aber das wissen sie. Und der letzte Satz dazu, also Pavoletti ist 35, Lappadula 33, also ist die Erfahrung pur. Aber da sind auch einige sehr, sehr spannende junge Spieler mit dabei. Es ist ein guter Mix. Oris Daniel von Inter aus Gelin hat schon getroffen. Also auch ein, zwei junge Stürmer, die viel Energie reinbringen. Ja, eine Feel-Good-Geschichte aus Sardinien.
Aber wirklich, könnt ihr euch noch an die Zeiten erinnern, als Werder Bremen Claudio Pizarro mit 41 Jahren gebracht hat? Und dann gab es so drei oder vier Spiele, wo er auch immer eingewechselt wurde und dann nochmal getroffen hat oder irgendwie was vorbereitet hat und so. Das sind schöne Geschichten.
Also es sind wirklich nur noch ganz kurze Zahlen dazu. Die letzten Tore von Pavoletti, 90 plus 9. Spielentscheidend. Davor 90 plus 4 plus 90 plus 6. Beide Spieleentscheidend, weil 3-3 und 4-3. Und eben dieses Aufstiegsdor, das Cali überhaupt erst in die Liga gebracht hat, 90 plus 4. Also ein kleines bisschen Magie steckt vielleicht mit drin.
Aber wirklich, das ist wirklich… Und dann hat er noch den Namen eines Operettensängers. Also Pavoletti, das ist ja… Also hier stimmt einfach alles.
Was will man mehr?
Was will man mehr? Ich kann dir sagen, was man mehr will. Nämlich die Spieltags-Awards oder unsere Awards. Kommt mir irgendwie vor, als hätte ich die schon mal anmoderiert. Weiß gar nicht, warum. Fabian, du darfst mal loslegen. Wer wäre denn dein MVP aktuell?
Also, wenn wir vorher bei Ude Las Palmas waren, habe ich mir dort auch jemanden rausgepickt, der ist im Moment in Spanien auch in aller Munde. Und das ist Kirian Rodriguez, der Mittelfeldspieler. Und der hat eine ganz besondere Geschichte hinter sich. Der war an ziemlich schweren Krebs erkrankt. Der hatte das Morbus Hodgkin-Lymphom, glaube ich, nennt man das, also eine bösartige Erkrankung des lymphatischen Systems. Und hat dort sehr lange daran zu kämpfen gehabt. War, wie gesagt, vor dieser Erkrankung schon fast so auf dem Sprung zu einem großen Club oder eventuell einer Nationalmannschaft dann natürlich der große Rückschlag. Und jetzt hat er sich zurückgekämpft. Er ist seit Januar diesen Jahres, glaube ich, wieder im Training. Im April hat er sein Comeback gefeiert. Aber jetzt erst zu den letzten Wochen ist er wieder richtig in die Mannschaft reingerutscht, ist wieder Stammspieler, ist absoluter Leistungsträger. Hat in den letzten Spielen den entscheidenden Tore zu den Siegen auch geschossen. Und ja, ist dementsprechend in Spanien jetzt wieder in aller Munde. Man kann sich vorstellen, wie glücklich der Mann an sich selbst ist, wenn er vor das Mikro tritt und einfach ein oder zwei Jahre nach der Erkrankung dasteht und gesundet ist und wieder auf höchstem Level Fußball spielen kann. Und wie gesagt, die Kanaden sind eigentlich sehr bekannt für technisch hochwertigen Fußball. Das zeichnet ihn auch aus und er ist dazu noch sehr torgefährlich. Er ist mit 27 auch noch nicht so alt. Und auch die nationale Mannschaft scheint wieder ein Thema bei ihm zu sein. Das geht in Spanien ja ziemlich schnell derzeit. Beispiel Brian Saragossa, der musste auch nur in Anführungszeichen zwei, drei gute Spiele machen und wurde gleich nominiert. Also ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass Luis de la Fuente auch, Kirian Rodriguez vielleicht demnächst mal beruft. Wobei jetzt, glaube ich, haben wir eine Länderspielpause bis März. Aber wir werden sehen, auf jeden Fall klopft er an die Tür.
Ja, eigentlich, also ich hätte ja gedacht, der Bayernwechsel wäre es bei Brian Saragossa gewesen. Weil ist es nicht bekannt, dass Bayern nur Nationalspiele hat? Aber gut, dann waren es halt die Leistungen. Aber das ist jetzt ein komplett anderes Thema. Uli, wer ist dein MVP aktuell in der Premier League?
Mehrfach genannt, trotzdem muss er genannt werden. Wer in einer Woche Manchester City und Arsenal schlägt, der verdient den Titel mehr als nur, ist inzwischen Tabellen-Dritter mit Aston Villa ohne Emery. Er ist immer noch gefürchtet in England. Obwohl es eigentlich einfach ist, das zu dekodieren, aber halt offensichtlich nicht zu spielen. Und es gibt genügend Teams, die passen auf das Matchup Aston Villa. Und deswegen sind die, glaube ich, ernsthaft zu Recht da, wo sie sind inzwischen. Ich hatte große Zweifel vor der Saison, aber alleine diese zwei Siege in einer Woche, die zeigen mir dann, die muss ich wohl offensichtlich deutlich höher einstufen, als ich sie bis dato eingestuft habe.
Nur zwei Punkte hinter Liverpool aktuell, Rang 3 noch vor, Manchester City. Ich habe einen Artikel gelesen von Sven Heist in der SZ. Der hat parallel zu Leicester damals in der Meistersaison aufgemacht. Würdest du so hoch auch schon greifen ins Regal?
Ich verstehe schon, woher er kommt. Was die Dynamik betrifft und die grundsätzlichen Vibes, die es wahrscheinlich schon gibt. Dass man sich denkt, es ist ein Villa, oder es ist immer so aufgebaut worden mit großen Namen, mit vielen Ablösesummen, dass man genau das machen kann, um herauszufordern. Ich glaube nicht, dass das auch nur im Ansatz vergleichbar ist, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Gut, dann hätten wir das auch geklärt.
Ich bin mir sehr leid, aber da muss ich mal ein bisschen länger drüber nachdenken, aber eigentlich gar nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist dann so der Klassiker, man sucht einen Referenzrahmen, den Menschen verstehen, die sich nicht viel mit der Premier League befassen, so wie ich hier immer mit meinen dummen Bundesliga-Vergleichen komme. Auch deshalb mache ich das, weil ich weiß, da finden sich viele Hörerinnen und Hörer zurecht. Und vielleicht ist es bei sowas dann auch, dass du dann einfach das Stichwort Lester wurde doch mal Meister fahren lässt. Dann wissen alle, oh krass, die müssen aber weit oben. Ach, haben die auch gegen Arsenal und City gewonnen? Ist ja krass. Vielleicht kommt es daher. Die Serie A hat ja auch einen aktuellen MVP.
Ja, und ich glaube, der hat sich das Prädikat auch redlich verdient. Es geht um Federico Gatti, Juve-Verteidiger, der am Wochenende das Spitzen-Spiel gegen Napoli entschieden hat mit einem Kopfball-Traffer 1-0. Das Besondere an der Woche davor, oder zwei Spieltage davor, hat er auch schon in der Nachspielzeit die Juve in Monza gespielt, hat in der Nachspielzeit das 1-1 kassiert. Und dann macht Gatti in 90 plus 7 auch das 2-1. Also ein Innenverteidiger, der zwei entscheidende Tore schießt, aber auch das ist noch nicht die besondere Geschichte an ihm, sondern es ist wirklich sein Werdegang. Gatti ist erst seit zwei Jahren Profi, also ist erst bei Fossinone sozusagen in der 2. Liga wirklich in den Profi-Alltag eingestiegen. Mit 17 ist er von der Schule abgegangen, weil sein Vater arbeitslos wurde. Er hat dann arbeitend die Familie ernährt, hat auf dem Großmarkt gearbeitet, hat als Maurer gearbeitet, jeden Tag um die 10 Stunden gearbeitet, ist dann abends noch ins Training in irgendwelchen Amateurklassen, ist um 11 Uhr abends nach dem Training heimgekommen, essen und um 3 oder 4 Uhr früh ging der Wecker wieder, weil er dann die Familie ernährt hat. Und aus dieser Geschichte heraus, quasi dann dieser Aufstieg, wie gesagt, noch mal vor zwei Jahren, erst Frosinone, dann hat er sich da in der Serie B wirklich als einer der besten Verteidiger etabliert. Juve hat ihn verpflichtet im Winter, hat ihn aber auch noch ein halbes Jahr da belassen, um ihm Spielpraxis zu ermöglichen. Und jetzt ist er wirklich fest integriert bei Juve. Erster Faktor, vielleicht erinnert sich der Uli noch daran, wir haben England-Italin gemacht, Nations League in der letzten Saison, da hat er sein Nationalmannschafts-Debüt gefeiert und hat 0-0 hat Kane verteidigt, zu Null quasi. An der Seite, ich glaube, das war sogar noch an der Seite von Chiellini, seinem großen Vorbild, also es ist wirklich eine Geschichte, die man so nicht wirklich oft hat. Und was auch noch das Ganze rund macht, er steht mit seiner Art und Weise, also er ist ein sehr körperlich starker, sehr aggressiver Verteidiger der alten Schule, also das ist unangenehm für Stürmer, das ist manchmal logisch auch ein Tick drüber, also da geht es halt auch darum, die Aggressivität zu dosieren, aber er steht halt auch damit für den Stil von Allegri und für Juve. Also Juve hat wieder diese Verteidigungsgier gefunden, dieses Kompakte und dann aber auch trotzdem gefährlich zu sein und dass dann einer wie Gatti jetzt Napoli entscheidet und Monza entscheidet, passt halt wunderbar an dieses Bild rein.
Zwei Sachen dazu, also zum einen ein gutes Auge Juve, muss man sagen, da dann quasi gleich zuzuschlagen, nicht zu sagen, naja, bei Frau Senone kann er es, aber kann er es auch bei uns an einem Champions League-Dienstag bei geschlossenem Dach, auch wenn sie das Dach, glaube ich, nicht schließen können. Aber ihr wisst, wie ich es meine, also es ist ja on a rainy Tuesday. Und das Zweite ist, wie schön es ist, dass jemand, der früher Mauern gebaut hat, jetzt einen Abwehr-Ballwerk bei Juve richtet. Bin ich bestimmt auch der Erste, der darauf hinweist?
Überraschenderweise nicht, aber ja, es passt gut rein. Wie gesagt, er ist wirklich, er verkörpert diesen Juve-Spirit im Moment, oder was heißt verkörpert? Er drückt ihn wahrscheinlich so aus wie kein anderer.
Nicht schlecht, Gatti. So, dann kommen wir zu den unbesungenen Helden. Fabian, du darfst wieder vorlegen. Wer ist denn aktuell der Unsung Hero in La Liga?
Jetzt habe ich die Sektion, glaube ich, ein bisschen besser kapiert. Und mein Unsung Hero ist dieses Jahr, oder dieses Jahr nicht, diese Ausgabe Trainer Mitchell von Chirona. Weil es wird viel über Chirona gesprochen und zu Recht natürlich auch. Und es wird viel über Spiele gesprochen, aber es wird mir zu wenig über den Trainer gesprochen, der für mich doch dann hauptverantwortlicher ist. Weil er –und das darf man bei der ganzen Sache vielleicht nicht vergessen –Chirona gehört zwar zur Man City-Gruppe zu einem bestimmten Teil und hat auch die Chance, den ein oder anderen Spieler dadurch leichter zu bekommen. Aber die besten Spieler aus dem letzten Jahr, zum Beispiel Tati Castellanos, der Stürmer, ist zu Lazio rumgegangen. Und viele Neuverpflichtungen, starke waren da jetzt nicht dabei bei Corona. Und man hat eher auf Spieler gesetzt, die so vom Konzept her passen würden, aber die vielleicht bisher in ihrer Karriere noch gar nicht groß ausgeschlagen haben. Und das tun sie jetzt aber. Dafür ist für mich einfach auch der Trainer hauptverantwortlich. Das ist kein Team mit großem Marktwert, da wurden keine Stars hingekauft, sondern da wurde wirklich symptomatisch gearbeitet, positionenbesetzt mit Spielertypen, wie der Trainer die in seinem System haben möchte. Und das greift wunderbar, wie man sieht. Dementsprechend ist für mich Trainer Mitchell dort hauptverantwortlich. Das kommt mir in der Berichterstattung dann teilweise ein bisschen zu kurz. Deswegen diese Woche mein Ansang Hero.
Sehr, sehr gerne genommen. Girona, aktueller Tabellenführer in La Liga. Und wen besingen wir dann in der Premier League, Uli?
Ich mache das dieses Mal ein wenig anders. Und baue mal die Kategorie um und nehme jemanden, den ich gerne ansinge. Es hat auch Gründe.
Der Uli-Sang-Hero.
Genau. Und ich nehme James Garner, Mittelfeldspieler von Everton. Also grundsätzlich hätte er auch genauso gut der MVP sein können. Die 10 Punkte abgezogen, sind schon wieder weg, sind schon oberhalb des Striches. Also alles schon wieder ausgemerzt. Haben jetzt wieder zweimal in Folge gewonnen. James Garner ist seit ewigen Zeiten der beste Ball-Playing-Mittelfeldspieler, den Everton hat. Den haben sie jahrelang gesucht. Was den so besonders macht, und deswegen habe ich den einfach mal genommen. Ich sehe den so gerne, weil der Flugbälle spielt. Das ist das Klausus-Thing zu David Beckham tatsächlich. Freistöße, so grundsätzlich auch, wie er schießt, also Schusstechniken, die verschiedenen Längen in seinen Pässen, also da kann von lang bis kurz echt alles. Ich sehe den einfach wahnsinnig gern. Das ist auch mit ein Grund, warum Everton generell zu meinen Lieblingsteams in der Saison zählt. Weil der auch ansonsten nie vorkommen würde, muss er einfach mal genannt werden.
Aber kann er die Six auch holgen?
Nein, aber er hat denselben Namen, das habe ich auf Twitter gelesen, erlaube mir diesen Fakt, er hat denselben Namen wie der Schauspieler von The Great Escape. Und da haben natürlich einige bei Everton draus gemacht, sehr gut. Wenn das nicht Self-Fulfilling Prophecy ist, dann weiß ich es auch nicht.
Das weiß ich wirklich auch nicht. Ok, sehr schön. James Garner von Everton. Damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet. Und mit wem habe ich in der Serie A nicht gerechnet?
Also wir müssen auch –ich muss es auch leicht anpassen, die Kategorie –wir müssen jemanden besingen, weil er seine Karriere Anfang der Woche beendet hat. Und zwar Giorgio Chiellini.
Vorhin schon kurz gezuckt, als du ihn erwähnt hast, bei Gatti.
Ja, ganz klar. Ein ganz, ganz großer des italienischen Fußballs der letzten ein, zwei Jahrzehnte. Er hat jetzt seine Karriere beendet. Er hat ja nochmal in den USA gespielt. Er hat jetzt das Finale verloren. Und er hat auf seine Art und Weise ganz ruhig gemeint, so, das war jetzt mein letztes Spiel. Das war es für mich. Man muss einfach noch ein paar Worte zu Giorgio Chiellini fallen lassen. Also, angefangen kommen wir mit dem Endeanfangen. Chiellini war der Kapitän der italienischen Nationalmannschaft, die in Wembley vor zwei Jahren sich zum Europameister gekürt hat. Und Chiellini ist wirklich ein Beispiel dafür. Also, erinnern sich wahrscheinlich die meisten noch, Chiellini war ein sehr harter Innenverteidiger, einer, der wirklich sehr unangenehm zu spielen war, aber der immer ein extrem hohes Standing bei den Gegnern hatte. Also auch der Fairness-Gedanke, klar, sind ein paar Grätschen von Chiellini auch mal da gelandet, wo sie nicht hätten landen sollen, gar keine Frage. Also, er war hart.
Und wen hat er noch mal festgehalten im Finale?
Saka im Finale, das ist logisch legendäre Memes, genau. Das passt aber auch zum Spieler Giorgio Chiellini, weil er wusste, wann musste er sich in den Dienst der Mannschaft stellen. Also die Kategorie taktisch-kleveres Foul, die musstest du Giorgio Chiellini nicht erklären. Der wusste, dass der Herr Saka da dann in dem Moment, ich glaube, es war die 120., da ist es dann besser, dann hält man den einfach zurück. Also, ja, eine ganz besondere Figur, ein ganz intelligenter Profifußballer, auch abseits des Rasens. Er hat ja schon während seiner Karriere bei Juve ein Managementstudium abgeschlossen, hat jetzt noch einen Master oben draufgesetzt, immer mit Bestnoten. Deswegen ist es auch nur eine Frage der Zeit, dass also Giorgio Chiellini wird eher in kürzerer Zeit als in längerer an den Schreibtisch kommen. Und das deutet logisch sehr, sehr viel darauf hin, dass das bei Juve der Fall sein wird. Er hat alle neun Meisterschaften mit Juve gefeiert. Chiellini ist ein spezieller Spieler, weil er auch einer ist, der über die Jahre noch mal besser geworden ist. Er erinnert sich vielleicht die wenigsten daran. Er war ursprünglich mal Außenverteidiger, ist dann ungeschult worden, weil er dann technisch dann doch nicht so stark war, um als Außenverteidiger halt auch mit Ball sozusagen Optionen zu bieten, ist dann zu einem legendären Innenverteidiger geworden. Hat sich aber auch in der Zeit noch mal weiterentwickelt, ist besser auch geworden. Klar, jetzt gehört er nicht in die Kategorie der ganz, ganz spielstarken Innenverteidiger, aber hat sich auch da ein bisschen steigern können. Und schön auch, was er jetzt am Ende seiner Karriere gesagt hat, er hat gemeint, auch er hat die letzten Jahre seiner Karriere noch viel mehr genießen können. So ab 31, 32 hat er all das richtig genossen. Davor war halt oft auch so ein bisschen Anspannung, Druck, wie auch immer. Und seit 31, 32 hat er gemeint, da war das echt alles ein Fest, was er da leben konnte. Er war eine riesige Führungsfigur für Juve, als auch für die Nationalmannschaft. Am Ende möchte ich noch zwei Zitate zu ihm, weil ich finde, die passen wunderbar. Das sind sehr schöne. Das eine war von Jose Mourinho, der damals, ich glaube, der war United-Trainer, wo er gesagt hat, Chiellini und Bonucci könnten an Haarwarten Lehrstuhl zum Thema Defensivarbeit leisten. Und das allerschönste Zitat, eines meiner Lieblingszitate aus dem Profifußball Alvaro Morata, der lange auch mit Chiellini bei Juve zusammengespielt hat, hat dann später, als er gegen Chiellini wieder gespielt hat, ich glaube, da war Morata bei Chelsea und sie sind in der Champions-League aufeinander getroffen. Da war ein schönes El País-Interview, da haben sie ihn gefragt, wer ist dein schwierigster Gegenspieler in deiner ganzen Karriere? Ich habe gesagt, da muss ich keine Sekunde nachdenken, das ist Giorgio Chiellini. Und dann die Frage, warum? Er hat gesagt, gegen Giorgio Chiellini als Stürmer zu spielen, müsst ihr euch so vorstellen, wie ihr werdet in einen Käfig mit einem hungrigen Gorilla gesteckt. Und eure Aufgabe ist es, ihm das Essen wegzunehmen. Das Fressen wegzunehmen. Und ich finde, ich liebe dieses Zitat wunderbar. Und ja, sagt sehr viel, finde ich, über Giorgio Chiellini.
Das ist aber nur die zweitgrößte Legende gewesen in dem MLS-Cup-Finale. Da linken nackt bei dir darf man, muss man natürlich in der Ligatour auch mal genannt haben, zum vierten Mal Meister geworden in den USA.
Genau, und ich finde es auch schön, dass wir dieses Finale damit angesprochen haben. Es gab nämlich einen Hörer, der hat vor sechs Wochen oder so schon gefragt, macht ihr dann nach dem Finale eine Folge und ich habe es mir dann auch notiert und so weiter, aber es kam der DFL-Investor dazwischen. Ich schaffe es leider nicht, tut mir leid, lieber Hörer. Aber schön, dass wir es auf diese Art und Weise nochmal angesprochen haben. Und Chiellini hat ja auch in der letzten Saison die Meisterschaft geholt. Also dass man jetzt wieder im Finale der Playoffs war, auch nicht so zufällig. Jetzt weiß ich gar nicht mehr, wo wir sind. Ne, wir sind schon durch. Wir sind beim Moment in La Liga. Das heißt, Fabian ist wieder dran.
Wir haben ein Momentum, das eigentlich nicht sehr schön ist, aber das ein paar schöne Anekdoten nebenbei hat. Das war eine ziemlich heftige Geschichte beim Spiel Granada gegen Bilbao. Da ist während der Partie ein Fan an einem Herdstillstand verstorben. Und das war irgendwie ziemlich kurios, denn der Torhüter von Bilbao, Unai Simon, hat ein bisschen mitbekommen, dass auf der Tribüne was los war, ist dann zu Schiri und hat dann gebeten, das Spiel zu unterbrechen. Er hat quasi diesen Spielabbruch so ein bisschen eingeleitet. Wurde deswegen auch von den Granada-Fans dann auch zu Recht, nicht gefeiert, aber ihm wurde dafür applaudiert. Es wurde dann versucht, den älteren Herrn, der schon lange Vereinsmitglied oder Dauerkartenbesitzer bei Granada ist, diesen wiederzubeleben. Das ist dann nicht gelungen. Dementsprechend haben sich beide Teams schnell darauf geeinigt, das Spiel abzubrechen. Das war in der 17. Minute schon. Bilbao hat dort schon mit 1-0 geführt oder 0-1 in dem Fall. Das Spiel war am Sonntag, es wurde dann am Montag wieder angepfiffen. Vor dem Spiel haben sich die beiden Kapitäne von Bilbao und Granada auf die Tribüne gegangen mit einem Trauerkranz und haben den dort niedergelegt auf den Platz des Fans, der dort verstorben war. Natürlich gab es eine Schweigeminute. Es wurde ganz schön inszeniert, die ganze Geschichte. Es war einfach eine ganz faire Geschichte zwischen beiden Teams, wie sie sich da verhalten haben und wie das alles abgelaufen ist. Das war mit Sicherheit der Moment des Spieltags in der Liga.
Da kann man wenig ergänzen. Das ist einfach so, das lassen wir einfach genauso stehen. Ein bisschen schwer danach, jetzt wahrscheinlich mit was Sportlichem zu kommen. Ich weiß nicht, Uli, was du in deiner Liste noch hast.
Mein Moment des Spieltags ist dann doch ein schöner, glaube ich. Mohamed Salah hat das 1-1 gemacht gegen Crystal Palace und damit seinen 200. Treffer für Liverpool im 326. Spiel. Und damit ist er das 1.5. in Liverpool durchaus weitreichender Geschichte, der das geschafft hat. Und vielleicht wird einem nochmal klar, wenn man sich vor Augen führt, wer alles nicht 200 Tore geschossen hat bei Liverpool. Da sind Namen drunter wie Steven Gerrard, wie Robbie Fowler, Kenny Doglish, wie John Aldridge, wie John Toschek, der nicht mehr in die Nähe kommt, Kevin Keegan, John Barnes. Also nicht nur das 200. Tor, auch das 150. Premier League Tor im Übrigen, auch da gibt es nicht so viele, die das gepackt haben, sondern das 1.1, das dann letztlich logischerweise wegbereiter war fürs 2.1 und damit auch die Tabellenführung für Liverpool. Ein schöner Moment, vor allen Dingen deshalb, weil man, glaube ich, manchmal so irgendwie gar nicht versteht, wie gut Mohamed Salah war und wie er oft einfach Dinge tut, die wir so für gegeben hinnehmen. Und 200 Tore, das ist schon echt sehr, sehr gut.
Aber absolut. Das braucht man jetzt nicht relativ.
Das würde ich unterschreiben, ja.
Aber hat er auch mal gegen Chilini getroffen? Das ist die einzige Frage, die jetzt noch zu klären ist. Wahrscheinlich hat er sogar das geschafft.
Gut möglich, ja.
Er hat dem Gorilla sein Essen weggenommen. Welchen Moment haben wir in der Serie A, Christian?
Ich habe auch noch ein sehr schönes Tor mitgebracht. Ich muss noch ganz kurz die Klammer, das hatte ich vorhin bei Pavoletti vergessen. Das Tor, jetzt 90 plus 9 zum 2-1, war ein Fallrückzieher. Nur so, das ist mir vorhin durchgerutscht. Mein Moment des Spieltags war, ich habe es vorhin angedeutet, es gab Atalanta gegen Milan. Es war ein sehr aufregendes Spiel, das Atalanta 3-2 gewonnen hat. Ja, tolles Spiel. Und das Tor fiel auch in der Nachspielzeit. Und zwar das 3-2 für Atalanta durch Luis Moriel, Kolumbianer, und zwar ein überragendes Tor mit der Hacke. Ich kann es nur jedem ans Herz legen. Wer Lust drauf hat, schaut es euch nochmal an, weil es ist ein grandioses Hackentor. Luis Moriel, Kolumbianer, mittlerweile auch schon über 30, mittlerweile nicht mehr Stammspieler bei Atalanta, weil er logisch auch mit Skamaka, mit Decetalare, mit Lukman, mit Thuré, der ja aus Spanien kam, der noch keine Sekunde gespielt hat, der kam für 30 Millionen und war bisher verletzt. Bei Atalanta ist auch die Tiefe im Angriff sehr, sehr gegeben. Moriel hat in der Europa League auch schon Tore geschossen, aber in der Liga hat er noch nicht getroffen, kam oft als Joker. Ich finde Moriel als Spieler großartig. Auf der Liste der fittesten Spieler würdest du ihn nicht ganz vorne finden. Das ist einer, der den Fußball im Blut hat. Der hat immer wieder solche Momente, hat großartige Tore mit dabei, weil er eine überragende Technik hat. Er ist beidfüßig, er kann mit links und rechts aus der Distanz abschließen, da kennst du keinen Unterschied. Er hat auch dieses Kreative, dieses Besondere, dieses kolumbianische Flair. Schaut es euch an, ein grandioses Tor mit der Hacke, das allein schon sehenswert wäre, aber dadurch, dass es auch noch die Entscheidung gegen Milan herbeigeführt hat und Atalanta jetzt dadurch auch wieder voll im Rennen und Platz 4 um die Champions League Plätze ist. Da ist es wirklich sehr eng. Da ist die Roma, da ist Fiorentina, da ist Atalanta, da ist Bologna. Also es war auch ein sehr, sehr wichtiges Tor, nicht nur ein sehr schönes Tor und dementsprechend der Moment des Spieltags.
Sehr, sehr gerne genommen. Und damit bleibt mir nur noch euch ganz herzlich zu danken. Danke, Fabian Pakulat.
Danke euch. Ich nutze die ganze Stunde und wünsche euch ein sehr schönes Weihnachtsfest. Genießt die Zeit. Lasst euch gut gehen. Uli, viel Spaß beim Boxing Day und wir sehen uns dann nächstes Jahr wieder.
Ach, sehr, sehr schön. Da kann man natürlich nur einstimmen. Uli, dir auch vielen herzlichen Dank und ebenfalls viel Spaß beim Boxing Day.
Vielen Dank. Ich wünsche euch da draußen auch alle viel Spaß beim Boxing Day, weil hoffentlich alle mit dabei sind. Sehr schön. Es gibt sogar einen Heiligabend-Fußball dieses Mal aus England. In diesem Sinne ein frohes, ruhiges Fest. Es war ein schönes Ligatour-Jahr.
Aber wirklich, das kann ich so zurückgeben. Danke dir, Uli. Und natürlich auch danke, Christian.
Ja, kann ich auch nur so mich anschließen. Vorher ist die Fanszeit sehr schön. Ich freue mich sehr, wenn es dann im neuen Jahr weitergeht.
Aber absolut. Und natürlich in Abwesenheit auch danke an alle anderen Gäste, die wir in diesem Jahr schon hatten. Die Ligatour ist ein ganz besonderes Format hier im Rasenfunk. Das, wie alles von euch finanziert wird, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und das könnt ihr jetzt auch via PayPal und Kreditkarte tun. rasenfunk.de slash-Supporters-Club. Da kann man dann auch mal so einen Einmalbetrag rüber schicken, weil Las Palmas mal angesprochen wurde in der Folge. Nur so als Beispiel. Das wäre doch ein guter Grund. Also danke für eure Unterstützung. Bleibt gesund, bleibt dem Rasenfunk gebogen. Und bis bald hier wieder. Macht's gut.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.